a humanitarian challenge is emerging in
Nigeria as the country experiences its
worst floods in a decade 33 out of
Nigeria's 36 states are affected by the
rising Waters entire communities have
been submerged losing their houses their
fields and their livelihoods so far more
than 600 people have died and at least
1.4 million people have been forced from
their submerged homes
the country experiences seasonal
flooding along these two main rivers
every year but on a far smaller scale
it's a different story this time take a
look at this section of the Niger River
as pictured in June this year and
compare with what it looked like earlier
this month when the river burst its
banks some communities have witnessed
water levels of up to 13 meters
we'll discuss why the situation is so
devastating after this report by DW's
flourish chikura
Southeastern Nigeria
and this is what the same Community
looks like now
swollen Rivers have inundated numerous
towns and Villages across Nigeria
causing 1.4 million people to flee their
homes for camps set up on Higher Ground
we are suffering but suffering is better
than stealing that's why we are here in
this condition the clothes that I'm
wearing are the only ones I have left
the flood carried away all our
belongings
I have an acre of farmland
and I bought a bag of manure for forty
dollars I planted rice
one and two days later the floods washed
everything away
all our schools have been destroyed by
water so our plea is anyone that can
help us should help us anyone that can
help us should help us please
but help is slow in arriving many roads
and bridges are washed out traffic
chokes those routes that are still
possible delaying the delivery of fuel
and Food Supplies around the country
we have just returned yesterday from
delivering Goods in the capital Abuja
and we are back here and we haven't even
gone an inch
look how ngos are scrambling to help
where they can
the situation is heart-wrenching
we have families where a single mother
with 10 or 11 children has lost
everything
the biggest challenge currently is the
shortage of food such a family needs
more than one bag of rice per meal and
they eat three meals a day
people in hot heat States like anambra
and for assistance promised by the golf
not seen any presence
with key infrastructure swallowed by
water many of the flooded communities
are without power and people's
generators have been destroyed
critical infrastructures such as schools
Health Care Centers police stations and
Banks can't operate and with the number
of farmlands that have been destroyed
there are concerns about food scarcity
in the coming months
Nigeria's government blames most of the
flooding on unseasonally heavy rain but
other factors play a role
the lad go Dam in neighboring Cameroon
opens its Gates every year releasing
excess water that flows into Nigeria but
Nigeria has failed to build a dam to
manage the Overflow the Nigerian
government says that though they
received early warning signs of the
flood they never foresaw this level of
Destruction and South Eastern Nigeria is
at risk of flooding until the end of the
rainy season in November
I'm joined Now by adaku echendu in
Ottawa she is an environmental
researcher at Queen's University in
Canada welcome to DW news Africa adaku
now you've been researching the reasons
for Nigeria's flooding um we know the
main rivers in the country flood
annually why is the situation different
this time
yeah the situation is different this
time because of the skill and magnitude
so why Nigeria is prone to an offloading
this year we've had very bad flooding
and the time of experience this kind of
flooding last was in 2012 and we have
similar factors so in 2012 there was
release of dams various damson from
Cameroon so that's the same they say so
even though this morning up the official
reports we have from the national
minister of Water Resources tells us
that the flooding we are experiencing is
not due to any it's not related to any
dam release but due to rainfall so have
hiring for this year
so so higher rainfall means the dams get
full and then they get released I mean
we've had a lot of rainfall before is it
exceptional this year
so apparently they've had very very high
and normal reinforce and this is one of
the impacts of climate change as
experienced over the globe but it's very
very important to differentiate the
Dynamics of Nigeria's flooding from the
global climate phenomena so climate
change is part of it but it's just a
very tiny piece of the of the puzzle in
the flooding problem in Nigeria so the
main reason for this flooding we are
currently experiencing is the lack of
infrastructure and poor planning
what kind of infrastructure are we
talking about that needs to be in place
and what kind of planning are you uh
should be in place to to prevent this
kind of flooding
Paul proper planning would mean that
there is no development on floodplain
place first of all so it's easy to blame
the people for building up floodplains
but when you have regulations if you if
you don't enforce them then people do
what they they do so you can't say
people are developing on floodplains
then secondly there's also
infrastructure engineering
infrastructure that should be in place
to help mitigate flooding as is they
practice all over the globe but sadly we
don't have that in Nigeria so that is
why the flooding is very very serious
what kinds of uh you say engineering
infrastructure what exactly are we
talking about can you give us examples
yeah so yeah yeah there are various
forms of engineering infrastructure that
could help mitigate flooding so you
could have reservoirs you could have
dams and actually in this flooding we're
experiencing they are reports that there
is a drum Nigeria is supposed to build
since
um many for many decades now that we
don't still have in place so there are
so many engineering experts that
engineering designs that we can put in
place to help control flooding for
example in the Netherlands so the
Netherlands is very prone to flooding so
they have a lot of structures in place
to control flooding but sadly sadly we
don't even have anything so I'm not
saying we should have um the type of
infrastructure in the lands have because
the Dynamics are also different but we
have nothing to actually help us affect
the equation of the effects of flooding
so that is why you see every year in
Nigeria most of the urban centers are
flooded and is this a resulting from the
lack of a strategy
[Music]
the policy in place I say this because
after the 2012 flaws we had the
government have had a post-disaster risk
management agenda and flooding is number
one on this list so it's a priority we
also have the National Water policy
which understands the need for
controlling flooding it acknowledges
that flooding is a threat so while while
there are some policies we do not have
there are also many others who have that
acknowledges the risk of flooding the
importance of preventing flooding but
sadly these are not uh implemented there
is no political will to implement what
we have
I spoke there with adaku echendu she's
an environmental researcher at Queen's
University in Canada